I'm going to tell you a story about a boy who would never grow up,...
...about the pirate who wished to catch him,...
...about the island where fairies roamed.
But this isn't the story you've heard before.
Because sometimes friends begin as enemies, and enemies begin as friends.
Sometimes to truly understand how things end, we must first know how they begin.
Welcome to Neverland!
It was written, when you return you'd unite our people against the pirates.
Mind if I cut in?
What if I fail to fulfill the prophecy?
And what if you fail to try?
If you don't believe, Peter, then neither will they.
You can't stay a kid forever even in Neverland.
Wakey-wakey!
Now, kneel.
I will never bow to you.
Do you know how to work a ship?
How hard can it be?
This is a lot harder than it looks!
We're sailing now!